Sab has been looking through those
figures talk us through them because
they're not looking great
good morning Kimberly no they're not the
average a wait time for things like
Category 2 phone calls which are
emergency phone calls for things like
heart attacks for things like Strokes
are now on average an hour and a half
more than an hour and a half and this is
for the first time this is significant
that this is half an hour longer than
the worst time on record and it's also
five times higher than the target time
which is 18 minutes now these numbers
are important for every 10 minutes that
emergency care is delayed for someone
suffering uh something like a heart
attack this means that there will be on
average an extra three deaths per 100
patients and that's according to a study
published in the European heart Journal
now December also saw more than half of
those people going to Major a e
departments they had to wait more than
four hours this has gone up by just
under five percent since November now we
know how hard it's been for the NHS uh
these past two years especially since uh
the pandemic and we've seen ambulance
workers nurses on strike they are under
significant strain and uh Sky News
earlier interviewed a doctor from an
emergency Ward who gave us a glimpse
into a life in a e take a look we're
incredibly busy we have been for a
number of months if not pushing on for
years now and there's something about
that when you're already at 100 capacity
and running as fast as you can you can't
go any faster so the Ed staff they're
working flat out as they have been for a
number of months when everywhere is
already escalated and running at maximum
capacity you can't step something up so
I think what we're seeing now is that
different areas of the health economy
and the wider system are having to step
up and escalate not just our emergency
department not just our ambulance
services not just our medical assessment
areas it's the whole system that's now
had to step up and run at a higher level
but there is some good news though the
number of uh or the data rather shows
that wait times in England since the
start of the pandemic so may 2020 around
27 months or so if my maths isn't wrong
uh has gone down so in October around
7.21 million people were waiting for a
routine appointment for surgery and then
this dropped 7.19 million the following
month in November so small gains but
they're important to stress especially
considering uh dropping waiting times
for Hospital appointments is one of the
prime ministers at priorities and
especially especially important when we
consider the strain that the NHS is
under